how are you doing today sir
good man how are you i'm doing excellent
i love this movie
this is going to be an easy five minutes
great
so i guess i got to start with the most
important thing um
obviously everyone wants to work with
fincher and uh getting to be a part of
this must have been amazing
but i do have to ask how much did you
pay to be in the movie
[Laughter]
i paid in sweat and toils steve i paid
in sweat and toil
uh david did not hand me this which is
something i really loved about him
uh but yeah no i i uh we i did i did
some rigorous auditioning
well i was going to ask you what is it
like when
how did you first find out that they
were they were considering you or was it
one of these like
how did you first get involved yeah so
they asked me to put myself on tape
which i did i was in atlanta at the time
filming ozark
um sent in the tape and honestly wasn't
sure i'd hear anything back because at
the time especially i had a long beard
and long hair and i'm like this just
none of this is right for joe
then a month later they said you know
fincher liked your tape and he wants to
zoom with you and then back then before
covert i was like what's zoom
um we we ended up on the zoom together
now i'm thinking like we're going to be
there there's going to be a reader
there's going to be a casting director
finch will be somewhere in the
background in the shadows watching
it's not the case we get on zoom and
it's just me and him
for 90 minutes just working on these
scenes talking going over them getting
notes
collaborating boom boom boom boom boom
we do that okay that went good he liked
it let's do it again
we do like another 90 minutes the next
week
it was so wild you know it's just me and
david fincher to zoom together working
which is cool in and of itself but
that's that's how it came about it was a
gradual process
yeah and uh so i want wanna jump now to
being you get the part
it's the first day of filming how scared
are you in a level of one to ten on that
first day of filming
zero i mean maybe a one yeah
no i just it's a weird thing but like
because i understand because it's you
know it's gary oldman and it's david
fincher and it's like oh this is going
to be intimidating but it has the
opposite effect on me like
i feel more relaxed because i feel like
everyone around me is really good at
what they're doing
and then you just have to show up and
kind of do your job
where like you're not worried that it's
gonna be bad it's dave adventure it's
like
you're here for a reason no i mean like
nobody forced
david fincher to hire tom pelfrey david
chose to hire me so like
you're here for a reason he wants you
here and also understanding like when
you get to work
that it's it's an impersonal thing we're
all there to
focus on the goal and so like it kind of
for me takes the personal feelings away
from it you know like
maybe a little bit of first day jitters
like a one or a two like you said but
like
by the end of the first day i was just
loving life
yeah i i'm very curious what was your
obviously the script
is the best blueprint you're going to
have going in but it's not a great
blueprint
for what the actual finished film is
going to be so i'm curious
what did you envision make being versus
when you saw the finished film
yeah i mean i guess this is what makes
fincher fincher but like as much as i
kind of imagined some version because i
do have to say like a lot of it was
there in the script you know like when i
was first reading that script i was like
this is incredible this is layering on
top of layer on top of layer like
the way we're talking about citizen kane
in a way that is like citizen kane like
in every possible way it felt like
the thing it wasn't exploring was being
explored
in the style of the thing it was
exploring you know so like a lot of that
was there in the script but then you see
what david does with it and it's just a
whole other level
but i mean i guess that's why he is who
he is you're like
whoa that's that's way better than i
thought even when i read it and i
thought it was pretty damn good on the
page
yeah he told me um and maybe he's
changed his ways but when i interviewed
him a few years ago he said that
one of the reasons he does so many takes
is he'll take like uh
something from take five something from
take 30 something from take 45
to craft someone's performance uh or to
get what he wants
uh did you when you were watching it did
you experience like any of that that it
was you know people you know pulling
from different things
i mean i'm sure he does i can't i can't
speak to exactly what that edit is like
for him but i will say like
he just has such a heightened awareness
of um
like visual and auditory like his his
senses are almost
off the chart in that way like a few
points where he was saying do this do
this to them i'm like why what what do
you
he's like come here well look at that do
you see that and i was like no
i don't i don't he's like don't you
don't see how that doesn't line up
perfectly with that i'm like no it looks
perpendicular to me
he's like it is painful living in here
you know and you're like
whoa this guy is literally seeing things
better than i can and so like i think
that's part of why he's so specific and
why he's such a genius because like
subconsciously any one of his movies
doesn't matter what they are to me
are beautiful like they're just so easy
to they're just perfectly
composed and told stories and i think
that's part of it i think that david
just has like a heightened
awareness of visual storytelling
and and how things sound you know which
obviously shows up in mink a lot
uh again love the movie you were great
have a fantastic time doing the rest of
the speed dating
thanks stephen later